Okay.
This is sort of funny and it's also very,
very depressing.
At a recent fundraiser, Democratic candidate
and former Barack Obama, vice president Joe
Biden made some promises to wealthy donors,
including that he won't quote demonize them
and that nothing big will change for them
if he becomes president of the United States.
And my reaction was, yeah, Joe, we know that.
I don't think you had to say that.
We know that Joe Biden basically saying the
quiet part out loud, making clear that his
politics are politics of centrist, status
quo, uh, center leftism and we knew that right
here is a list of what Joe Biden had to say
just a couple of days ago.
To a group of rich donors in New York City.
Joe Biden told them, I need you very badly.
Joe Biden told these wealthy contributors
in New York City, no one standard of living
will change.
Nothing would fundamentally change.
Joe Biden said that rich people are quote,
just as patriotic, as poor people.
Joe Biden said, quote, we may not want to
demonize anybody who has made money.
And Joe Biden said, I hope if I win this nomination,
I won't let you down.
Meaning you rich people who are giving me
money.
We know Joe, we know this is, this is actually
great.
In a sense.
This is confirmation about exactly what we
will get with Joe Biden.
We knew that Joe Biden was the status quo
economic policy would some slight leftward
moves combined with moderately left social
policy.
That's what we could expect from Joe Biden.
And he's confirming it here.
This idea of nothing will fundamentally change.
That's literally status quo.
Centrism it's, I'm basically in the middle
and slightly to the left on, on social policy.
Uh, and I'll make some tweaks on economic
policy, but nothing is substantively substantively
going to change.
He needs the rich donors.
He's not going to do anything that's going
to be scary to them and he's telling them,
I'm safe for you.
I will say stuff on the campaign trail about
economic justice and inequality and paying
of people's fair share and all of this stuff.
But that big picture, he'll work around the
edges and he's not going to substantively
change things for them.
Uh, other than playing in the margins a little
bit.
So this is the exact opposite of change.
You can believe in.
It's no change and you can be sure of it and
you can safely vote for me without worrying
that I'm going to take too much of your money.
He's saying there will be some cake crumbs
for the middle class and the poor sprinkled
on them, but that big picture, the rich are
going to keep their full rich decadent black
forest chocolate cakes or whatever analogy
or metaphor you want to apply here.
This is like a really memorable non story
of the campaign in the sense that we knew
that this was why Joe Biden was the safe establishment
candidate.
He will say mostly the right things in public
on policy.
Now he has gaffes obviously, uh, but he is
going to be completely predictable in his
governance.
There is not going to be anything earth shaking
that will happen.
And in a sense this is very similar to what
we expected with Hillary Clinton when I've
said that a Hillary Clinton presidency would
have been boring in a sense.
It's because she would've been predictably
center left.
We would have as a progressive show critiqued
her from further to her left.
She wouldn't have done anything that would
have generated the worldwide cartoonish embarrassment
that Donald Trump has generated.
But it would have been all of the expected
stuff.
There would've been some crumbs for the lower
and middle class and there would have been
status quo center left foreign policy period,
a big picture.
And Joe Biden is effectively the same as far
as that goes.
We know what we get with him and in a sense
I think it's a good thing that this is now
out in the open.
Uh, the contrast between Joe Biden and people
like Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren is
now much more clear, vote for what you want.
And it's now really clear what it is that
each candidate is offering.
I actually, I've said before, I don't really
understand undecided voters two months or
a month before the election, once we've had
the debates and once we've had the primaries,
I really don't understand how someone could
be undecided at that point in time because
it's so clear how different whatever candidates
remain are at that point.
And even when you look at Hillary and Trump,
very, very different.
I Know Hillary is a center left Democrat,
but very different than Donald Trump.
And I didn't understand how someone could
be undecided a few weeks before the election
in 2016 as people would call in and tell me
that they were right.
Now I understand saying, you know, I'm on
the Progressive Wing.
So for me it could be worn.
It could be Bernie, it could be somebody else.
If they end up being the nominee and if it's
Biden, I'm going to vote for him because he's
better than Trump.
Right?
Like it's super clear to me at this point,
sort of how someone might be in that mode.
But what at this point is really great that
has come from these revelations from Joe Biden
and private, is that there is no more question
about what a Joe Biden presidency would be
if you had any question remaining, which many
of us who follow this stuff didn't safe for
very rich people.
Crumbs for the lower and middle classes and
a center left foreign policy.
That's what we can expect and it's abundantly
clear and now we can all support the candidate
that we believe most aligns with our values.
I want to hear from you, what do you make
of these statements by Joe Biden in private,
although we now know what was said, uh, to
very wealthy donors in New York City.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
Follow me.
Let me know what you think.
And while you're there, follow the show on
Twitter
as well@davidpakmanshowthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com